deutschland wird nach masken jetzt in
dieser schwierigen zeit ist
unternehmerischer mut gefragt auch für
windige industrie einsteiger wie mich
jetzt brauche ich expertise ich besuche
deswegen den godfather of textile
trigema boss wolfgang traub
der gruppe ich grüße sie einen schönen
guten tag herr hawelka
ich versuche jetzt auch ins geschäft
einzusteigen weil ich merke das sind die
zeiten wo man natürlich wenn man gute
ideen hat wo man wo man unter umständen
auch eine gute marke machen kann wir
haben es nicht vorgehabt durch die krise
zu profitieren sondern wir wurden
aufgefordert oder gefragt von den
kliniken und pflegeheimen ob wir nicht
kurzfristig masken produzieren könnten
weil das ein mangel wäre
so das ist also die yamamoto az 80 20
usd x5 dfb 20
na ja wenn zwei ist bei uns gerät
[Musik]
sehr gut er ist kinderleicht verstehe
gar nicht warum es dann nicht auch
kinder machen eigentlich sind ja kinder
dafür gedacht dass sie solche arbeiten
aber ich möchte jetzt auch an ich möchte
jetzt auch unternehmer werden ich habe
dieses diese existenz als autor beim
fernsehen oder so das ist ja nichts
halbes und nichts ganzes was ich
mitbringe auf jeden fall ist ist die
vision und und auch in form von
autorität und uns selbst nicht im
auftreten das ist jetzt blauer stoffe
das gute aussehen auch was man sonst
noch es sie müssen vor allem ein
miteinander mit ihren mitarbeitern sehen
denn das ist ganz wichtig ich kann hier
nur erfolg haben wenn wir gemeinsam
diesen erfolg auch auf durchstehen
ich spiele heute schon gemacht 1000
stück ja seit seit wann sind sie es ist
sie heute hier seit 6 uhr am 1000 stück
gemacht jetzt haben wir haben wir elf
das heißt also in fünf stunden 1000
stück ja dann das heißt natürlich wird
schon ganz gerne wenn schon ganz gut
wenn wir heute noch 30.000 fertig machen
das wird also da heißen dass sie doch
ein paar sprüche machen müssen davon die
leute züchtigen das sicher nicht sie
müssen den mitarbeitern klar machen dass
sie als ehrbarer kaufmann auch für alles
was sie an weisen persönlich in der
verantwortung stehen das bin ich das ist
schließlich die maschinen etc absolut
gar nicht so viel das passiert so bin
ich wusste zwar auch wie man es macht
aber sie könnte man gerade machen was
kostet so ein zehnerpack also die wir
verkaufen die masken im online für 1220
euro den zehnerpack so dass die maske
zwölf euro kostet aber sie können eben
online bei uns als treuebonus bis zu 25
prozent rabatt erhalten so dass die
maske dann nur noch neun euro kostet
dann müssen sie die mehrwertsteuer
abziehen
sie kommen also dann praktisch im
verhältnis zu dem wenn sie bei uns
größer kaufen da können sie ab 7 euro
bis zu sechs euro wenn sie 1000 mehr
kaufen erhalten und alt im online ist
der preis identisch für zehn stück wie
wenn sie 100 stück bei uns zu 7 euro
warum machen sie sich einfach ein adidas
logo drauf dann können sie masken sogar
für 24 euro verkaufen
das dürfte ich rechtlich gar nicht und
ich sag mal in diesen zeiten ist es egal
hauptsache ich habe innovative ideen für
hochwertige rasch masken ja nehmen dass
wolfgang grob und in null komma nix
gehört der weltmarkt nie dass das nicht
100 prozent textil ist sozusagen würde
ich das von meiner warte aus sicher
nicht unbedingt unterstützen
also bin ich mit der die durchgefallen
bei ihm das müssen sie ihre frau fragen
[Musik]
ja it-service beweise sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren sie doch
mal den kanal der heute show auf youtube
zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung